[Musik]
sally chan hat geschafft wovon viele
junge menschen träumen sie verdient mit
videos über kochen und backen im
internet geld sally ist youtuber ring
einer der erfolgreichsten in europa
wir als gewinner vom feld zu gehen das
ist alice welt
ist es wichtig dass man wirklich
authentisch ist das heißt man kann nicht
einfach schauspielern und sagen wie
stets da kann gut backen und kochen und
tun so als er die spaß dabei man muss es
auch wirklich lieben rund um ihre koch
und back videos hat sie ein unternehmen
aufgebaut
sallys welt ein geschäftsmodell das vor
wenigen jahren noch gar nicht denkbar
war kann man nur machen und auch ein
eigenes unternehmen aufbauen zwar auch
wenn man talent hat aber es hat auch
disziplin haben die eine million
abonnenten erreicht sally ist
marktführerin und ein star ein simples
backrezept war der grundstein zu einem
rasanten erfolg
[Musik]
also ich finde es nicht dass ich berühmt
bin aber dann sagen andrea doch schon
aber ich sehe deshalb selber nicht so
einfach
die erfolgsgeschichte von salis welt
spielt im nordbadischen waghäusel mitten
in einem wohngebiet
hier lebt sali berisha alias sally mit
ihrer familie ehemann murat und den
beiden töchtern samira und erlauben noch
ist zeit für ein gemütliches frühstück
doch das wird sich gleich ändern
[Musik]
sallys küche ist wohl eine der
berühmtesten im internet das herz ihres
unternehmens und innerhalb von minuten
verwandelt in ein hochprofessionelles
filmstudio sally beschäftigt eine eigene
film vor
[Musik]
rund dreimal die woche gibt es ein neues
rezept video von sally auf der
internetplattform youtube jedes einzeln
er hat im schnitt 300.000 aufruf ein
spitzenwert
der aufwand finanziert sich durch die
werbeeinnahmen von youtube sally wird
daran beteiligt da große unternehmen
gerne werbung vor sex videos platzieren
verdient sie gut damit
ich habe die werbeeinnahmen von youtube
immer wieder investiert also ich hab
dann nicht gesagt mensch habe ich
taschengeld ich mach mal urlaub sondern
ich habe gesagt ich habe ein ziel ich
möchte bessere videoqualität haben also
hole ich mir personal dazu und hab halt
und großen schritt gewagt und gesagt
mensch jetzt investiere ich mal ein
bisschen mehr geld in eine gute kamera
hat dann die nächsten jahre auch
wirklich eine tolle kamera und auf dem
top stammt und es war bisher zum glück
mal gut
vor fünf jahren hat sally erschien ihr
erstes rezept video veröffentlicht
seither sind 100 wird dazu gekommen
mein ziel war der größte flop zu werden
und so eine art lexikon aufzubauen das
heißt immer dann wenn jemand ein rezept
zu hoch sondern eben auch meine videos
am zurückgreifen um meine videos finden
und ich glaube das haben wir echt in
schneller zeit auch sehr gut geschafft
es ist erst das zweite dass wir das
füllen und werden die kühe steht machen
wir schon mal die trauben ein drehtag
beginnt mit einer ausführlichen
besprechung der tag wird lang
der dreh aufwärts acht bis zehn stunden
für ein video für die tat habe ich jetzt
hier schon mal was vorbereitet und zwar
habe ich bereits die kuchen wurden
gebacken und weil ich gestern keine zeit
hat so hart
also wenn das bild oder der ton wenn das
nicht schön ist und ich ansprechen da
macht auch gar kein spaß videos
anzuschauen und dann ist natürlich der
inhalt ganz wichtig das heißt gerade bei
meinen rezepten
es muss alles kleinen schritt ich sein
und so dass es eben auch jeder versteht
ich muss halt gucken dass ich jetzt
nicht nur die profis abhole sondern auch
schon die anfänger und die videos müssen
eben so gestaltet sein dass
fortgeschritten oder profis nicht
gelangweilt sind weil es eben zu klein
strittig ist aber schon so dass es jeder
eben allgemein und versteht also der
inhalt muss passen aber eben auch die
technik dahinter
dabei hilft ihr ursprünglicher berufs l
ist ausgebildete lehrerin studium habe
ich gelernt wie man alles praktisch so
reduzieren kann
dass es grundschüler verstehen und ich
habe einfach den ansatz wenn es
grundschüler verstehen dann verstehen es
auch erwachsene und vor allem auch
männer
[Musik]
ihre spezialität sind so genannte motiv
tor extrem aufwendige gebilde die es so
bei keinem konditor zu kaufen gibt
[Musik]
solche torten muss man selber machen und
dabei helfen sallys videoanleitungen es
dauert stunden ist ein solches kunstwerk
fertig ist und es gilt unzählige
einzelne arbeitsschritte in eine
sinnvolle reihenfolge zu bringen
[Musik]
eine torte in form eines weinfass es das
video dazu gibt es erst einige tage oder
wochen später auf youtube zu sehen denn
es wird noch geschnitten und bearbeitet
am ende der dreharbeiten taucht ihr mann
murat auf und kündigt das neue video
schon mal per smartphone in den sozialen
netzwerken hier postet er live auf der
plattform facebook und innerhalb von
minuten rufen zehntausende fans sallys
facebook seite auf um sich murat
smartphone video live anzuschauen
dazu einige hundert kommentare die
umgehend beantwortet werden social media
ist ganz wichtig und bei uns wird jeden
tag gepostet auf mehr mut und tag ich
muss natürlich auch die verschiedenen
sozialen medien füttern also youtube ist
was anderes als facebook das ist auch
wieder was anderes als instagram und da
muss wirklich jeden tag was passieren
dass man einfach auch nicht den kontakt
zu den zuschauern verliert hat vor
kurzem der e mail erreichbar zuschauerin
sylvie und moral sind immer noch live
über facebook mit ihren fans verbunden
was sich jetzt abspielt läuft ohne 3
ganz spontan
auch das ist ein kapitel der
erfolgsgeschichte
es gibt unzählige koch und back videos
im internet aber nichts reicht an sallys
erfolg her
sally hat den schritt raus aus der
digitalen welt des internets gewagt
hinein in die reale welt
sie ist mit ihrem team auf der messe in
dortmund sally hat eine eigene
kollektion herausgebracht bug zu gehör
debug rahmen tortenheber rührgerät aber
auch merchandising produkte und eigene
kochbücher alles produkte die in ihrem
auftrag hergestellt werden der verkauf
läuft über den online-shop und auf
messen
[Musik]
sally hat in einen großen messestand
investiert den aufbau macht sie mit
ihrem team selbst
die die ab
ich bin
also vor zwei jahren war die erste messe
es war aber nur eine ganz kleine messe
da haben wir auch tische gemietet und
tische aufgebaut mit tischdecken
abgedeckt und die kartons darunter
versteckt und seit etwa einem jahr wird
diesen großen messestand und er wächst
natürlich von messe zu messe wir
bekommen immer mehr besucher dann merken
wir okay der letzte war wieder zu klein
also wieder ein bisschen anbauen und wir
sind ja normalerweise keine menschen
baualter keiner von uns und wir sind
alle irgendwo reingefallen ins kalte
wasser
aber ich denke meistern das so ganz gut
[Musik]
nicht nur die chefin pakt mit einem
sondern auch die mitarbeiter aus dem
online shop der kameramann der fotograf
der profis 25 mitarbeiter beschäftigt
sallie mittlerweile und fast alle sind
hier dabei
[Musik]
zum stand gehören eine große
verkaufsfläche und eine showküche
während der aufbau noch läuft arbeitet
sie schon für den nächsten tag vor
denn sie erwartet tausende besucher
normalerweise sage ich auch immer ich
bin ganz aufgeregt aber ich bin dann
schon so kurz vorher doch schon
aufgeregt ja viele menschen doch schon
die messe kaye campbell gilt als größte
messe für torben gestaltung und deko
backen in deutschland eine boomende
szenen und hier gibt es viele aussteller
die ein ganz ähnliches geschäftsmodell
verfolgen wie sally bike spezialisten
die ihr know how über dekoratives gebäck
den workshops oder internetvideos
weitergeben und dazu spezielles zubehör
anbieten aber keine ist so erfolgreich
wie sally sie hat nicht nur den größten
messestand sondern sie füllt sogar eine
eigene halle
kurz vor messebeginn wird nochmal für
ein youtube video gedreht
sally lässt ihre fans im internet an
fast allen ihren unternehmungen teil
aber ich hab im backofen nächste mal
wohl nur einen mit pyrolyse mit selbst
reiniger funktionen die man muss nur
noch shoppen macht nicht einfach dabei
trauen und dann öffnet sich das tor zu
sallys messehalle
[Musik]
dicht vor augen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist dann auch so nicht so ganz real
in dem moment ich schaue mir das video
danach an und denkt ach gott waren das
viele menschen und das kann man in dem
moment gar nicht so fassen und ich muss
auch sagen die drei tage die ziehen dann
auch echt an mir vorbei und ich bin da
wie auf weiß nicht also ich glaube das
adrenalin auch wahrscheinlich im körper
aber so ganz verstehen tue ich das
glaube ich immer nie in der situation
sondern erst später
sonst wäre ich wahrscheinlich umfang vor
aufregung während sally auf der
showbühne zu gange ist läuft nebenan der
verkauf ihrer produkte
die fans sind in guter kauflaune
das geschäft boomt
[Musik]
sie haben ein buch und ein t shirt für
alles von sally für sie
nein ich habe doch die große verehrerin
mitgebracht die lena du musst auch hier
richtig shoppen ist toll
sally muss man haben und da gibt's ja
jeder messe superklasse warum muss man
sally haben weil sally kult ist was
findest du hier so toll also ihre
ausstrahlung und schwarze einfach
anstehen für ein autogramm manche müssen
stunden warten und kommen doch immer
wieder
letztes jahr war ich auch ziemlich spät
waren man muss sich auch zwei stunden
anstehen
ich brauche halt gesagt aber stetig
letztes jahr war mir auch hier und haben
dann die lange schlange gesehen habe mir
gesagt okay machen wir nicht diesmal
sind wir früher aufgestanden früher
losgefahren
jetzt stehe ich hier und warte bis zum
12 aber auch das glück ist ein autogramm
hatte ein autogramm 111 ii und ein idol
zum anfassen
[Musik]
hunderttausende fans folgen ihr
regelmäßig in den sozialen netzwerken
und doch scheint sally zu vermitteln
sie ist kein star aus einer
unerreichbaren welt eine gruppe gebildet
und dann haben wir angefangen zu
schreiben so genannte geworden eine
sally like gruppe praktisch also wir
können uns jetzt auch schon seit
anderthalb jahren und das ist jetzt das
erste mal dass wir uns alle treffen und
ist natürlich schön weil wir das
weltinteresse mögen die gleichen
personen und es macht immer spaß
das ist auch einfach jeder art dass man
durch ihre videos glücklich wird und
saniert ist nicht nur die rezepte da ich
lieb' eintrete art und dann macht das
schauen so viel spaß und es ist einfach
schön
herzlich willkommen so salis wellen
heute möchte ich mein fünfjähriges
jubiläum feiern ab und so hat es vor
fünf jahren angefangen ihr erstes
youtube-video das rezept ein muster das
erste video kam so zustande ich habe
damals noch studiert kommt und
hauptschule abend und das hauptfach war
hauswirtschaft mein lieblingsfach
und ich habe immer gern gekocht und
gebacken und torten waren eigentlich
immer so mein spezialgebiet und dann
haben mich immer die familienmitglieder
oder freunde oder andere studenten nach
den rezepten gefragt und ich habe sie
immer ganz umständlich immer weiter
gegeben wie sie darauf die idee gekommen
den 18
doch einfach ein tutorial also eine
anleitung mit video und das gab es auch
damals derzeit auf deutsch zumindest
noch nicht und das war so das erste
video und da habe ich mir dann nutzt auf
ausgesucht vier mal habe ich gefilmt und
hat mich dann irgendwann getraut das
video hochzuladen und ja so war das
start und kam sofort super an
per also über nacht habe ich 1000
aufrufe gehabt und es war echt enorm
viel wenn ich überlegt also ich kenne
ich mal 1000 leute zu dem zeitpunkt
zumindest noch nicht und so hat das
ganze angefangen mit einer ganz kleinen
digitalkamera ja in der küche mit einem
karton ohne stativ und das war der start
von salis welt
dann habe ich gemerkt mensch das macht
mir so viel spaß ich bin noch mehr
machen nicht nur ein video die woche
sondern wirklich 23 videos in der woche
und ich konnte nicht mehr im lehramt
tätig sein und youtube parallel machen
weil ich sehr anstrengend war also
gerade wenn ich ans staatsexamen zurück
denkt ob als erster oder zweiter da saß
ich da wirklich habe für die prüfungen
lernen müssen unterricht vorbereiten
müssen und haben 18 auch videos
geschnitten
da hat jeder andere gesagt hatte wir
doch verrückt hat doch auch mit youtube
und ich hab gesagt dass ich mein ziel
ich will weitermachen ich will einen
großen hut kanal haben und alle sollen
meine videos kennen und das war echt
sehr anstrengend da schmeckt immer also
wir leben running gag in den rezept
videos ist ein auftritt von ehemann
murat der das fertige gericht
kommentiert sally und murat ein ehepaar
ein team
die videos sind weit mehr als rezept
anleitungen es ist sallys welt die darin
spielt ihre familie sind die
protagonisten und was die familie gerade
erlebt ist thema kindergeburtstag
einschulung und sogar die
schwangerschaft
sally lässt die fans unmittelbar an
ihrem leben teilhaben
ich möchte heute wieder ein kleines
schwangerschafts update machen ich habe
euch auf instagram und auf facebook
gefragt was ihr dann wieder aktuell für
fragen habt youtube lebt hat auch
einfach davon dass es eben ein bisschen
privater ist als im fernsehen man hat
ein bisschen mehr einblick kann ein
bisschen hinter die kulissen schauen und
es ist ja auch ganz schön aber eben
immer bis zu einer gewissen grenze
und auch für ihr nächstes projekt
liefert die familiengeschichte das 3
sally ist mit ihrer familie freunden und
fotograf marius im garten ihrer eltern
in der nähe von bad ischl
sie bringt ein neues kochbuch heraus mit
türkischen und mediterranen rezepten
so ein bisschen zur seite
samira von mira chance mehr ein gericht
für das kochbuch sind gefüllte
weinblätter der garten ihrer eltern
liefert dafür die zutaten und die
kulisse für die fotos das neue kochbuch
ist für sally eine herzensangelegenheit
[Musik]
um ihren ganz wichtig als ich bin auch
familienmenschen ich verbringe viel zeit
mit meinen eltern und mir meinen
geschwistern und das braucht so kann man
auch ist in meine eltern diesen seit
über 40 jahren in deutschland und seit
damals aus der türkei gekommen und haben
sich auch hier kennengelernt und haben
hier wirklich hart gearbeitet und man
muss dazu sagen dass ich da auch echt
stolz drauf bin weil sie wirklich ohne
deutschkenntnisse gekommen sind und sich
viel aufgebaut haben dann habe ich
gedacht also wenn meine eltern so was
hinbekommen und wirklich so dieses
durchhaltevermögen haben dann muss ich
ja das auch können
und ich denke dass den fleiß dann habe
ich bestimmt von meinen eltern und auch
das durchsetzungsvermögen aber man muss
halt echt diszipliniert sein
weiter geht's in der küche in waghäusel
die schaltzentrale des unternehmens und
multitasker in saly führt regie
dann muss ich jetzt überlegen was sind
jetzt rezepte für mein buch was ihr noch
rezepte für den dreh für den youtube
kanal und dann habe ich so etwa 100
sachen am tag danach immer so eine liste
die heutige liste was wir alles abhaken
müssen und abarbeiten müssen und dann
komme ich mal ist nichts durcheinander
und ich mag es meistens nicht
während auf der einen seite schon für
das kochbuch gekocht wird macht fotograf
marius noch ein paar fotos von der torte
vom vortag für sammys blog zwischendurch
schnell noch ein paar instagram und
facebook kommentare beantworten und dann
geht es weiter mit den gefüllten
weinblätter das rezept dafür stammt von
salis mutter viel von der mama
mitgenommen
vor allem hat meine mama immer selber
gekocht immer frisch gekocht waren
früher nie in restaurants essen haben
kein fastfood gegessen und es hat mich
schon sehr geprägt
nachdem
das rezept weil ich finde werde das geht
es natürlich schon lange nicht nur von
meiner mama
es gibt auch in vielen ländern in
griechenland kenne ich das auch und in
der türkei ist es auch ganz beliebt und
jeder macht es anders und ich muss dazu
sagen die version von meiner mama ist
die beste und das sage ich nicht mal
zwei normal ist
für das neue kochbuch hat sally ihre
lieblingsrezepte aus dem familiären
umkreis zusammengetragen
aber auch rezepte die sie auf reisen
durch die türkei und ums mittelmeer
entdeckt hat
wenn man die bilder anschaut
also das soll ein schon das wasser im
mund zusammenlaufen aber da vertraue ich
auch ganz unser marius der macht es
wirklich super und wir entscheiden dann
noch kann man zusammen welches bild rein
kommt welches durch wegfällt oder ob man
vielleicht das essen noch mal irgendwie
anders anrichten muss und da spielen ja
auch verschiedene faktoren
[Musik]
knapp drei monate später ist das
kochbuch in druck in einer heidelberger
druckerei sally und ihr team bringen das
buch in kompletter eigenregie raus
rezepte texte fotos grafik layout alles
selbst gemacht im unternehmen
sallys welt
[Musik]
es ist ihr viertes kochbuch und weitere
sollen folgen
jedes jahr ein neues so ist ihr plan
[Musik]
es ist ein schönes gefühl da fällt einem
so dass stein vom herzen
wobei noch nicht komplett also wenn das
buch gedruckt ist und ich sind das in
der hand hat ist es schon mal so einen
schritt näher zur zielgeraden aber so
richtig dass stein vom herzen fällt mir
erst dann wenn ich das feedback bekommen
von den zuschauern
also wenn die dann das buch sehen und
sagen mensch sehr tolles buch oder ich
habe schon ein rezept ausprobiert und es
gelingt alles super und das ist dann so
der punkt wo ich irgendwie so eine
erleichterung dann habe und ja dann
wieder mich auch etwas anderes
konzentrieren kann zum beispiel auf die
entwicklung von neuem back zubehör sally
ist auf dem weg in den kraichgau zu
einem ihrer zulieferer
sie legt wert darauf dass ihre produkte
in der region entstehen und nicht in
asiatischen billiglohnländern
in waibstadt sitzt die firma laves eine
kleine blechmann fabrikation mit zehn
mitarbeiter die firma stellt hochwertige
back rahmen backformen grundfläche er
auch sallys produkte werden hier in
ihrem auftrag und nach ihren wünschen
produzieren heute geht es um die
entwicklung einer sogenannten teig karte
die torten spezialistin hat ihre eigenen
vorstellungen wie dieses produkt
aussehen soll
dinge die man braucht und wie teuer sind
als das war für uns schon schon ein
glücksfall wir profitieren beide
voneinander
ja es sind einfach gute ideen die sie
bringt vom bereich bangen
wir hatten natürlich auch die
mitarbeiterinnen wir haben überwiegend
weibliche mitarbeiterinnen
trotzdem bringt diese lieder nochmal
ganz andere richtungen ganz andere ideen
rein
ich versuche schon so weit es geht
wirklich alles hier zu produzieren vor
allem wanderer ebenso team fahren kann
und sagen kann mensch das hätte ich doch
ein bisschen anders oder vielleicht hier
noch eine idee und heraus da kann es
auch echt immer super umsetzen die sich
wie albert einstein in der branche dem
sage ich eine idee der setzt sich hier
abzeichnet ist auch sofort und dann kann
ich dann wirklich auch sagen mensch die
qualität passt das passt jetzt so und
das produkt stimmt und vor allem
unterstützt man natürlich auch die
region aufs wechsel rollen wechseln die
unternehmerin unterwegs in der youtube
glamourwelt
[Musik]
im düsseldorfer iss dome wird der web
video preis deutschland verlegt es ist
der wichtigste preis für videos im
internet vergleichbar mit dem deutschen
fernsehpreis ein gesellschaftliches und
vor allem mediales großereignis in der
branche sally ist nominiert sind
aufgeregt ich bin zum ersten mal beim
webvideo kreis mit dabei und nach zum
ersten mal direkt nominiert deswegen
weiß ich gar nicht wie das ist alles
abläuft und ja schon bisschen aufgeregt
es gut geschlafen hat nacht nein ich
habe nicht gut geschlafen aber ich hoffe
man sie jetzt nicht beim webvideo preis
zeigt sich die ganze bandbreite der
internet video welt beauty bloggerinnen
musiker schräge vögel selbstdarsteller
journalisten filmemacher wissenschaftler
gamer es sind die stars und idol der
generation internet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
video preis hier raus ffc sally ist
nominiert in der kategorie food es gibt
noch zwei weitere nominierte und es
bleibt bis zum schluss spannend
deswegen haben wir uns gedacht da muss
es eine neue kategorie zu diesem thema
geben
mal gucken wer es geschafft hat hier als
gewinner vom feld zu gehen es ist salis
welt
geschafft töchterchen samira darf mit
auf die bühne
hallo herzlich willkommen kommen zu uns
bist du immer dabei wenn ich manchmal
dreht nicht immer aber du versuchst es
möglich zu machen oder gibt es irgendwas
wo du sagst ja da bin ich wirklich
spitze
ich denke beim motiv torten bin ich da
ganz konkret welche motive hast du
gemacht auch schon ganz ganz viele
zusammen was kann sie am besten
schokokuchen dann gratuliere ich euch
und wünsche euch ein schönes hey es hat
geklappt herzlichen glückwunsch
dankeschön ja wer den preis gewonnen
samira ist und das ganze team wir sind
alle überglücklich dass doch ein
tränchen verdrückt zur moment ja habe
ich also wirklich die anspannung ist
groß und dann kommt natürlich der ganze
druck und fällt irgendwie von einem ab
und ja wirklich wirklich schön
ich bin wahnsinnig stolz auf meine frau
und auf die ganzen jungs die dahinter
stehen und arbeiten wirklich klasse ich
habe gedacht das müssen meine ich
gewinnen das geht eigentlich anders
und dann habe ich am anfang erzählt otto
vielleicht kommt doch was dazwischen
oder war ich mir ganz ganz unsicher und
dann als die kamera auf uns gezeigt habt
dann ich aus mir heraus gebrochen habe
ich sagte wow das muss es jetzt sein war
echt cool glück nicht toll
klasse
zwar nutzen person luft also ich finde
ein webvideo preis an sich richtig toll
und man kann wirklich auf youtube sein
talent zeigen und wirklich sich austoben
ausleben was aber für nicht zu kurz
gekommen ist dass man eben auch wirklich
arbeit reinstecken muss weil wirklich
auch viele kinder und jugendliche wenn
man die heutzutage fragt was möchtest du
mal werden die sagen nicht mehr ein
schauspieler oder sänger die sagen ich
möchte youtuber werden weil einfach
keiner die arbeit dahinter steht und man
stellt sich nicht einfach vor die kamera
und redet es gibt natürlich auch aber
ich denke um wirklich erfolgreich zu
werden gehört eben bisschen mehr dazu
als talent da muss man wirklich das
durchhaltevermögen haben man muss
vielleicht auch ein bisschen
wirtschaftlich denken können man muss
stories spielen können und man muss
einfach diszipliniert an die sache gehen
und auch mal sagen mach daran weniger
freizeit
und hier entsteht das nächste kapitel in
sallys geschichte eine gewaltige
investition in die zukunft die jungen
unternehmer bauen geschäftsräume und
einen privaten wohnteil für die familie
[Musik]
ja also hier sehen wir jetzt in unserem
küchenstudio sozusagen
hier kommt dann später die büchereien
und hier kann ich auch die videos drehen
deswegen haben wir auch eine hohe
deckenhöhe damit wir kameras nicht darum
alles anbringen können ohne dass wir
später immer wieder alles abbauen müssen
das heißt hier bleibt dann alles stehen
haben wir ein büro für etwa zwei
personen hier schon ein bisschen
größeres büro unter arbeiten dann auch
echt alle hand in hand das heißt hier
sitzt dann die grafik gewinnen dann
sitzen die jungs vom schnitt da und da
kann ich über die schulter schauen und
sagen mensch schneidest du so oder so
hier können wir auch das backbuch das
kochbuch produzieren und alle sind
einfach zusammen dh wir haben dann auch
kein home office mehr es gibt keine
herumtelefonieren reife und es passiert
doch alles ein bisschen schneller und
effizienter
hier sind wir da jetzt in unserer
familienküche das ist dann nur unsere
private küche also ich denke die werden
wir trotzdem auch zeigen wollen die
zuschauer bestimmt auch mal sehen und es
auch ganz interessant wie richtet sie
sich jetzt privat ein und berichtet sie
jetzt die youtube küche ein
ein mutiger und großer schritt für die
gerade mal 28 jährige unternehmerin
bei youtube ist es wirklich so man muss
sich um sich auch klarmachen heute im
trend morgen vielleicht schon wieder auf
aber wir haben ja nicht nur youtube wir
haben ja auch unseren eigenen onlineshop
wir machen eigene produkte die bücher
zum beispiel essen und trinken wird man
heute wird man aber auch noch in 20
jahren
und man muss sich halt einfach immer
weiter entwickeln so sieht jetzt die
fertige torte aus und fand es ihr die
auch nach machen möchte dann geht
einfach aus alles welt de
ich wünsche euch schon mal ganz viel
spaß dabei und auch im guten appetit bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]